the imitation game was nominated for
eight academy awards today including
Best Picture Best Actor and Best
Director pin spoke with the film's
director Morton chilled him on his
experience telling the untold story of
Alan Turing I think it's impossible to
not be amazed and outraged when you hear
the story about Alan Turing I mean I
always loved the history I thought I
knew history really will and I was
shocked about how little I knew about
hunter I mean why wasn't this man on the
front cover of my history book when I
was at school I mean his achievements
are so staggering and I'm turning when
he was 23 years old he theorized the
computer 1936 I mean he was so ahead of
his time and when it was 27 he joined
mi6 at Bletchley Park and led a team
that cracked the Nazi and Emma code
which meant they have access to Nazi
Germany communication and I mean within
Churchill has said that he did the
single most important achievement during
Second World War the cause of him would
be the work that did this group did the
war was shortened by years and I think
up to 14 million lives would say because
of it now you mentioned that he never
really received the credit as you as you
described said how come he wasn't on the
cover of the history books that you grew
up with in Norway right all kept it
secret it was it's one of the best-kept
secret in the history of intelligence
and several decade were not I mean it
was like 40 50 years before people who
actually knew the important work I did
so so he sort of like been erased from
history a little bit and sort of pushing
this shadow in history this man who did
so much which we own so much too he's
his I think is one of the big thing is
one of the big geniuses of the last
century's one of the most recent
headlines having to do with Hollywood
has to do with hacking zoni privacy the
confidentiality of information based on
your understanding of Alan Turing what
do you think he would feel about the
cyber security but also the issue of
privacy he was a man who carried around
secrets his whole life so I understood
their value all completely
I mean and this is also remember not
only him but the whole group who was at
Bletchley Park nobody talked and today's
age is is it's it's mind-blowing to
think about that this this group who
broke enigma who did this incredible
achievement for the war nobody talked
nobody talked two decades about what I
did it was it was if the government held
secret and and in this age when there's
no secrets that lasts more than 20
minutes it's it's pretty mind-blowing to
think about just as you described it's
different from today has the revelation
that our communication would
particularly the communication let's say
it Sony is up for grabs that almost
anyone can have access to it is that
changed the way that you interact with
your friends your family you're
performing it really makes you think
what you're going to put out there it's
it's it's and it's kind of frightening
that that that I mean the privacy is in
you is there's no real sense of security
anymore and or safety so so I think it's
and I think what happened and not only
that but but you also have to look at
what it will do for art what it will do
for movies in the future I mean if
self-censorship self-censorship is is is
that's what everybody is afraid of now
are we going to afraid that this movie
will offend somebody who will then use
cyber attack and hacking as a mean to
later blackmail the movie for not being
shown well they now start to stop
studios and production companies to
think okay maybe we should not make this
movie because later on some will be
offended and they might do that you know
threaten us so so hopefully doesn't come
to this because you know it's it's it's
it's whole essence of art is that we
have yet should provoke somebody
somebody should be provoked at somebody
or at least made thinking you know and
and and so so that is that is a scary
part of what happened that just only
attack that it died it hopefully it will
not make Studios production companies
more reluctant to to finance it start
production that make may
somebody in the future tell us about the
commercial success of the movie and how
that's in a sense been a surprise maybe
to some people it's it's been a huge
commercial success which I'm really glad
I babies and more people are you know I
mean there are no superheroes in it you
know now it may mean bragging it's these
nerdy mathematicians who are breaking
codes and possible but it is a
fascinating story and I think the
injustice that happen to him it is
relating also it's a thrilling movie and
say it's a spy trailer it's a war movie
it's also a love story thank you and and
people are really responding to it and
as a filmmaker it's been phenomenal all
right now we'd like to get to know
Morton told them just a little bit more
little better hey so I would like to
know what is your favorite movie I can
tell you what my favorite movie
experience was that was watching Star
Wars when I was a kid you can sit there
in the dark and be taking somewhere you
never knew you could be taken the other
any let's say thanks Hollywood or
international film stars that you wish
that you could have had a chance to work
with I would love to do moving Marlyn
Monroe visit that would be interesting
to see if Morton told them could not be
a movie director what would you like to
do I would either be an architect to
build houses or I would make video games